So we have seen in most of our
examples that we have used pages of
four kilobytes, and in the most recent
quiz we have used larger pages.
So how do we choose the page size that
we're going to support in our processor?
So comparing smaller
pages to larger pages,
larger pages are good because they
will result in a smaller page table.
The page table needs
to have one entry for
each page that we are using in
the case of multi-level pages.
So, if pages are larger, we would
have fewer entries in our page table.
Smaller pages will suffer
from large page tables.
So it seems like larger pages are good,
but
we can only give memory to
applications in units of pages.
So if you have a very large page,
we will suffer from what is
called internal fragmentation.
Internal fragmentation occurs when
the application requests some amount of
space, let's say this much, but we can
only give it space in terms of pages,
so we end up giving it, for example,
two pages, where this space in this page
is not really used by the application.
That means that whenever this
page is actually in memory,
it is going to be using actual
physical memory, although in fact
only this much of it is being
used by the application, so
this much physical memory is going to be
wasted whenever this page is in memory.
When the page is on disk, this is also
wasted because we store the whole page
on disk, but
this is maybe less of a problem
because the disk is usually much
larger than the physical memory.
So how do we choose the page size?
Well, obviously,
we want smaller page tables but
we don't want to suffer from too
much internal fragmentation, so,
just like with the block sizing caches,
we want to reach a compromise.
And it turns out that the good
compromises are at page sizes from
a few kB to a few MB.
That is why x86 processors
use a 4kB page.
At the time when they were designed,
the bias was slightly more toward
the smaller pages because we were so
worried about wasting memory.
Nowadays, waste of memory even
with megabyte sized pages
is relatively small compared
to the overall memory size, so
if we were designing
a processor nowadays,
probably the page size would be closer
to a megabyte than to a 4kB page.